foreign
let's go to Julie oh right down the
street in Nashville Tennessee what's up
Hi how are you I'm good what are you
doing
well I'm hanging out in my car talking
to you
I'm I Hey listen
in 2023 I'm trying to be more mature and
there was like three jokes that I was
about to make that I did not make
because I'm trying to be more growed up
so I want all of America to know all 19
listeners uh I'm growing up okay so
Julie you're in your car chatting with
me what's up
well I'm calling to ask your opinion
um we're thinking about putting our
daughter into a private school but we
are middle class this is an elite
private school
um and how do we cope with
um or how do we help her cope with
feeling different from other kids and
will it be um more damaging to her to
attend this school or to go to public
school after we have to move to
Pennsylvania to um try to get her a
better education in a public school
Julie
I've already taken a vaccine call on
this show now you're giving me the
public school private school call
yes
Kelly they're trying to cancel us on the
first episode all right Julie
um well here's the deal I promised on
the show never lie that was like one of
my core tenants when I took this show uh
I mean when I decided to do this and so
I was going to tell you the truth as
best as I know it and then I'll tell you
about my own kids and then we'll go from
there is that cool
yes okay let me ask a few questions
first why
hell number one how old is your kid
um almost 11. okay okay why are you
worried about public schools
or why why a public school
I'm sorry why why a private school yeah
oh okay so she's already been in private
school through Elementary School school
okay
um yeah
Point um we're looking at going into
middle school and we're wondering if
that's something we should continue with
or if we should go on to public school
but this is not the place for public
school not where we live
um the schools are not great here and I
it's my responsibility to provide her
with the best education that we possibly
can
so what
um
hmm
what makes the schools not great
I think that the academics they're just
not up to par I have a relative who um
taught in the schools here he'll say
yeah they're okay okay
um there are no advanced classes at all
no AP courses no extra
enrichment for kids that would benefit
from that there's just nothing and then
I have talked to a few
um students who graduated from the
school hear us and they said they didn't
feel prepared for college at all okay
and they did well in high school
um
so you're thinking about moving or
thinking about mortgaging
yeah mortgaging your souls to pay for
private schools
is there a little bit where
like I've had a really crummy car a
bunch in my life actually and the car is
so junky it's just it's just like
falling apart it's not good it gets me
where I need to go but it's just awful
yeah and I end up looking at cars that
are like nine rungs above where I should
be looking
right have you hit the pendulum so far
let me no no
sometimes we do get financial aid okay
no we don't have to come up with all the
money is that what you mean no no no I'm
talking about
you're following so I worked in
education for um for two decades okay
private schools public schools private
universities public universities I've
worked in across the gamut okay my kids
have gone to a private school and public
schools okay so there is some data
that exists about kids who go to private
school end up with better outcomes
test scores
um ACT scores SAT scores College
admissions and things like that
right I believe with all my guts and
until I see a study that shows me that
I'm wrong which I'll get on the show and
say hey I was wrong I don't think it
exists
I think that's an much more about an
inputs question than an outputs
meaning I agree
uh for those listening
if you live in a community and it's full
of surgeons and you know bajillionaire
businessmen and women who are sitting
their kids in a private school well
you've self-selected into a school and
the school can reject kids or not let
kids in who aren't of certain academic
quality so you get a selected group of
kids who are then of course are going to
go on to have high test scores but that
has very little to do with the with the
education right
um even if you look at Harvard a study
just came out the Harvard grade
inflation everybody gets A's there now
everybody they always make a change and
so you can look and be like man Harvard
puts out only people who have four O's
no they don't they just give everybody
A's right the community college class in
rural Oklahoma who takes a kid who can't
read and then gives that kid some skills
to go get a job that's I mean you see
I'm saying so the institution you're
falling prey to
um
you have to give your kid the best if
you really love that kid
right and there's only one best and
that's us and we're 58 000 a year
right from sixth grade oh there are
other ways to get there I agree so
um my wife often reminds me she's the
one who is the K-12 scholar
um she was Dr Delaney long before I was
she's way way smarter than me
um
she reminds me often
John did we go to college yes
do we read to our kids yes
do we have books in our house yes do we
all have dinner at uh table regularly
yes our kids are going to be fine
those are the data points okay now when
you get to college prep and all that
that's a whole thing I went to an
incredible Public High School in Houston
and I was very prepared for college so
it doesn't matter
um
is there something deeper here is this
purely academic so you worried about the
social stuff or are you worried about
that kind of drama
yeah pretty much like there's already
been some talk of Lily lives in a little
house we don't live in a little house
like but you know like what is and then
she'll ask me questions like why can't
we have an SUV why do we have to drive a
little car like you know things like
that that can she can internalize and
take that into her future and I don't
want to do that to her
I grew up
um
a poor kid in a very affluent community
and I consider that one of the greatest
privileges of my life even though it was
awful and I have a lot of trauma and
scars from it
thank you
oh no okay uh and here's what here's
where the trauma and scars come from we
didn't talk about it
okay
that's where and so when you don't talk
about stuff they become secrets and
secrets feed shame
and shame is something's wrong with me
because our house is too small
something's wrong with me because we
only have two I only have two pair of
shoes
I only have one jacket or coat
great see what I'm saying that's
different then no this is how we choose
to do it we're choosing to have us like
the house I live in right now is pretty
small house and I tell my kids like we
intentionally chose a small house I like
all my kids I like everybody in one
little like close to us and we're doing
that there you see and so talking about
no no we're making choices
yeah we could go mortgage our souls and
get a brand new Lexus and pay 1400 a
month why that's dumb it's a
depreciating asset we buy used Camrys
they're awesome yeah and so I'm teaching
my kids to be proud of the choices they
are making and proud of their particular
station
okay does that make sense so we're we're
talking about it my kids have no idea
what kind of resources we have
look you see what I'm saying
yes and I want it that way okay so
I think this is hard because there are
some really crummy difficult
um Public Schools
they exist
and a 50 or 60 000 a year private school
may not solve your problems
or that may be taking a sledgehammer too
a mosquito
okay
is there an in between
yeah and there are a lot of options okay
to make that happen yeah have you fallen
prey to if we need to get the best and
if we don't get the best I'm failing my
kid and I'm gonna have to take a second
job and a third job and all that
the best we don't necessarily have to do
the best but we are going to do better
than what we have locally okay I think I
think we're committed to that okay
um
here's my big picture my kids go to uh
Public School
if when I'm on the Internet it's on
social media which
it's not a ton
nothing gets more pushback than when I
tell people that my kids go to the
public schools and so I'm going to make
this super clear I want my kids
exposed to nutty ideas
I want my kids exposed to whackadoo
people
with strange ways of doing the world
I want them exposed to that while they
still live in my house
because they're gonna get exposed to
that in college they're going to get
exposed to that in the workplace they're
going to get exposed to that ever you
cannot live your life now I don't want
my kids exposed to violence I don't want
my kids exposed to terrible teachers and
awful administrators which sounds like
that's where you are who just are not
academically challenging at all I don't
want that yeah absolutely
um but it's my job to teach my kids
spirituality it's my job to teach my kid
community and resilience and how to come
back from harder things my kids have had
teachers that weren't great
and God can you imagine being having Dr
deloni and Dr deloni with three
doctorates in education coming and
sitting down and staring across me and
you're a third year teacher I mean it's
not even fair so we try to be nice my
wife and I but like there's been some
teachers that weren't great and so we
got to teach my son you're gonna have a
boss that's not great or you're gonna
have a client that's not great and
they're gonna be really tough to work
with here's how you you're right it's
how you persevere and so I think there's
some metal lessons there that are so
good I'm not Outsourcing that stuff
that's my job
yeah and I there is a balance but I'm
I'm going right through the middle of it
um
I I would not worry if you do go to
private school I would not worry about
your kid being the whatever kid in fact
I would celebrate their friends parents
does that make sense
yeah
um yeah like so-and-so's Dad is a
surgeon man he cuts open people's heads
for a living his mom replaces Hearts she
makes so much money they take care of
them like I I mean I would celebrate it
right
yeah we're gonna do that you see what
I'm saying like just hold it really open
yeah this is who we are This Is How We
Roll can I ask you one personal question
absolutely do you feel less than
no actually no I don't I I work with a
lot of the people that she goes to
school with but parents of the children
and
um they treat me really well
um yeah we're good so you don't feel
like if you accept financial aid that
you're some kind of Charity case and
that you're some kind of
no no no this is um part of part of our
family's Journey okay because your kids
your kids will absorb that
okay and I want you to be really proud
of the choices you're making for your
kid whatever your choices happen to be
and by the way I don't hate on private
schools
um if there's a great private school and
we my wife and I chose to use our
resources that way we'd definitely do
that
um one of my kids may end up in a
private school someday but I don't have
any any
uh ill will towards them at all
um I just hear some of the reasons
people choose to go and I it just sounds
nonsensical what you're saying is really
powerful I think
like you're concerned about your kids
grades all right or what your kids will
learn right
um I do think that matters I think
that's important and if you're going to
school and they're they're just sitting
you on Khan Academy or telling you to
watch online videos something that's not
teaching and it's not learning you need
some engagement with real humans who are
walking thing walking you through things
and again that's not opinion that's just
from the data
um
your kid's gonna be your kid and your
kid is going to absorb the lessons they
get from you there's gonna be bullies
everywhere and there's going to be more
on kids everywhere and there's going to
be
the rich kid and the super poor kid
everywhere
kids desperately need their parents to
be anchored in number one together Mom
and Dad together and they need to be
anchored into a set of values is who we
are we choose to drive used cars we
choose to live in a smaller house we
choose to
live in a huge house this is how we
choose to do it we have extra bedrooms
anybody can come stay with us whenever
they need a place to to come visit we
choose to have a lake house so that we
can go hang out whatever your life is
own it
don't let your kids absorb your shame or
let themselves feel less than oh no
good for you Julie for loving your kids
thinking it through carefully
um I would say there's another option
before you mortgage everything
and if you do end up going that route go
for it stand tall
your kid's gonna do great